[Music]
aliens enchiladas what is this world
coming to
or should I say what is coming to this
world this is what if and here's what
would happen if we found alien life on
Enceladus first of all it's pronounced
Enceladus nut and coladas
sorry muchacho Enceladus is Saturn's
sixth largest moon but it would be
better described as a winter wonderland
winter because it's covered in ice and
has an average surface temperature of
minus 200 degrees wonder because just 40
kilometers below its surface are the
ingredients for life are there aliens
out there how long until we know for
sure this is the waimangu geyser it
doesn't exist anymore but when it did it
could shoot water 460 meters high making
it the largest geyser ever known on
earth but beyond our atmosphere waimangu
is a drop in the bucket if you want to
see a real geyser you should book a trip
to Saturn in September 2005 NASA's
billion-dollar Cassini space probe was
approaching Saturn when it detected huge
eruptions at the southern pole of
Enceladus this tiny moon is roughly 25
times smaller than Earth but it's
geysers are eight thousand times bigger
than anything recorded on our planet
Cassini recorded bursts that went as far
as 240 kilometers into space which is
about the distance from Washington DC to
Philadelphia but if these bright blooms
of mysterious vapor were a sight to
behold scientists were more in awe of
what remained hidden beneath 40
kilometers of thick ice there's an ocean
on Enceladus and it's remarkably similar
to the oceans we have on earth where
life might have begun the data collected
by the Cassini space probe indicates
that the water on Enceladus is salty and
is likely heated by hydrothermal vents
if Enceladus is ocean works like our own
it's expected that these subsurface
vents expelled hydrogen rich hot water
which mixes with organic compounds to
create amino acids which combine to form
proteins the ingredients for life our
planet is estimated to be about
four-and-a-half billion years old the
earliest evidence for life on Earth
comes from fossils that were found in
rocks that were roughly 3.7 billion
years old today and salad Asst is
estimated to be about 1 million years
old which if it's following the
earth-like timeline would put it at the
right age to start supporting life but
considering that for 90% of our planets
history life on Earth was microbial
chances are that alien life on Enceladus
would also be microbial the big question
is what might these aliens look like
we're talking about creatures formed in
cold dark water with no access to
sunlight how would they interact with
their environment would they glow in the
dark or would they see without eyes how
might they evolve in size and in
intelligence and will we ever find them
or will they find us
that is a story for another whatever